dear and fox joining us great Sacramento
after the 124 123 Kings win over Golden
State swiper thanks a lot for taking a
few minutes with us man I appreciate you
problem at all so here's what here's
what I want to know because games like
this are so different here in the
inseason tournament with the point
differential and all that when you guys
are down 17 at the half to Golden State
was everybody aware that 12 was the
magic number for Golden State how much
was that
discussed uh after after we were done
with our meeting uh some of our
assistant coaches let us know what it
was um but coming back out man we we
wanted to win the game we wanted to we
obviously this still goes against our um
our regular season record so we still
wanted to win the game but we did know
what the number
was dearen Malik monk 21 points but the
game go-ahead field goal uh to give you
guys the the onepoint lead what can you
say about what he's brought this season
man uh I think he he's done it last year
as well and I think even the year before
that when he was in LA um he's a spark
Off the Bench he's able to play make he
can put the ball in the basket and
honestly for me that's not the toughest
shot that I've ever seen him make going
back to high school and college so uh
him making that obviously it's an
extremely tough shot but uh he he's done
that for us time and time
again dearr you guys have been lows and
highs in your entire time in Sacramento
now y'all are considered a legit
Contender have you you notice how teams
prepare for y'all different like every
night y'all go out it's like no we got
to play or they're going to beat us
definitely I feel like there's a respect
level uh that you get in the league uh
once you're you know considered a good
team and uh for me I was patient
throughout the years obviously a lot of
years before me as well but I tried to
stay the course I tried to continue to
grow uh as a player individually while
we were going through those times and
obviously we we have a roster uh that
was put together great and our coach
coaching staff has been phenomenal for
us so um it it's fun going out there
knowing that you you give yourself a
chance every time you step on the floor
you know darar you know individually
you've taken jumps over the last two
years what have you done personally as
the team has taken but individually what
have you done for me it's contined to
stay the course obviously uh all the
questions for me were uh what can I do
outside the ark and um I think I'm
continuing uh to continue to get the
better at that uh year in and year out
um obviously there are times where I
have to take and make tough shots but
you know when I have those open ones
especially with the way that we play I
have to be able to knock those down and
Luke L has been big for me uh since the
day that he was hired he came down we
started working out and we've almost
seen each other every day since since he
was
hired 2910 and 7 for dear and Fox
tonight the Kings win the group you'll
be home next week against New Orleans
hoping to light the beam and go to Vegas
we appreciate the time man thank you yes
sir thank you guys have a good
night